as you heard I'm a physicist and I think
that the way we talk about physics needs
a little bit of modification
I am from just down the road here I
don't live here anymore
but coming from around here means that I
have a northern Nana my mum's ma and
Nana is very bright she hasn't had much
formal education but she's sharp and
when I was a second year undergraduate
studying physics at Cambridge I remember
spending an afternoon at Nana's house in
Ernst Ann studying quantum mechanics and
I had these folders open in front of me
with this
you know hieroglyphics let's be honest
and now that came along and she looked
at this folder and she said what's that
and I said it's quantum mechanics Nana
and I tried to explain something about
this these what was on the page it was
to do with the nucleus an Einstein a and
B coefficients and and now that looked
very impressed and then she said or what
can you do when you know that don't know
Nana and I think I said something about
computers but and it's because it was
all I could think of at the time but you
can broaden that question out because
it's a very good question what can you
do and you know that if when that is
physics and I've come to realize that
when we talk about physics and Society
or in our sort of image of it we don't
include the things that we can do when
we know that our perception of what
physics is needs a bit of a shift and
that only doesn't need a bit of a shift
but this perspective sharing this
different perspective matters for our
society and I'm not just saying that
because I'm a physicist unbiased and I
think we're the most important people in
the world honest so the image of physics
right we've got an image problem let's
be honest it hasn't moved on much from
this this is a very famous photograph
it's from the Solvay conference in 1927
and this is when the great lines of
physics were grappling with what it you
know with the nature of determinism and
what it means only to have a probability
that a particle might be somewhere and
whether any of it was real
and it was all very difficult and you'll
notice that they're all very stern
looking men in suits I'm Mary Curie I
keep nearly saying Marie Antoinette Mary
which wouldn't be a turn up for the
books and Marie Curie third from the
left on the bottom now she was allowed
in but she had to dress like everybody
else so this was the this resistive this
is the you know this is what physics is
like there's all this kind of
hieroglyphics these are to do with waves
and particles that is an artist's
impression of two black holes colliding
which makes it look worth watching to be
honest I'm glad I didn't have to write
the risk assessment for whatever was
going on there the point is this is the
image of physics right it's weird and
difficult it's done by slightly strange
people dressed in a slightly strange way
it's inaccessible it's somewhere else
and fundamentally why should I care and
the problem with that is that I'm a
physicist and I study this this this is
my job
right I study the interface between the
atmosphere and the ocean the atmosphere
is massive the ocean is massive the thin
layer that joins them together is really
important because that's where things go
from one huge reservoir to the other you
can see that the sea surface I was that
was me took this video the average
height of those waves by the way was 10
meters so this is definitely it's
definitely physics happening here
there's lots of things this is
definitely physics and you know it's not
included in our cultural perception of
physics and that bothers me
so what is included in our cultural
perception of physics well so because
I'm a physicist there has to be a graph
right that's allowed and so we've got
time along the bottom here from very
small very fast things that very long
things that take a long time over here
small things at the bottom big things up
there so our current cultural image of
physics looks like this
there's quantum mechanics down in that
corner it's very small it's very weird
it happens very quickly and it's a long
way down in the general you know on the
scale events in the matters for everyday
life and then there's cosmology which is
up there very large very far away also
very weird and if you go to some places
like black holes in the beginning the
universe those who join up around the
back and we know that these are
frontiers in physics right there's lots
of work being done to this
govenor physics in these places but the
thing is you will notice it's a very
large gap in the middle and in that gap
there are many things there are planets
and toasts and volcanoes and clouds and
clarinets and bubbles and dolphins and
all sorts of things that make up our
everyday life and these are also run by
physics u-visa but there is physics in
the middle it's just that nobody talks
about it and the thing about all of
these is that they all run on some a
relatively small number of physical laws
things like Newton's laws of motion
thermodynamics some rotational dynamics
the physics in the middle applies over a
huge range from very very small things
to very very big things you have to try
very hard to get outside of this and
there is also a frontier and research
physics here it's just that nobody talks
about it and this is the world of the
complex when these laws work together
they bring they bring about the
beautiful messy complex world we live in
and fundamentally this is the bit that
really matters to me on an everyday
basis and this is the bit that we don't
talk about there's plenty of physics
research going on here but because it
isn't it doesn't involve pointing at
stars people somehow some reason think
it's not there now the cool thing about
this is that there's so many things in
this middle pit that this middle bit all
following the same physical laws that we
can see those laws at work almost all
the time around us I've got the video
here so the game is one of these eggs is
raw and one of them has been boiled and
I want you to tell me which ones which
it's good that you know which ones are
raw the one on the left yes and even
though you might not have tried that you
all knew and the reason for it is that
you set the spinning that's all right
and then when you stop the cooked egg
the one that's completely solid you stop
the entire egg when you stop the other
one you only stop the shell the liquid
inside is still rotating because
nothing's made it stop and then it
pushes the shell around again so that
the egg starts to rotate again and this
is brilliant right it's a demonstration
of something in physics that we call the
law of conservation of angular momentum
which basically says that you set
something spinning about a fixed axis it
will keep spinning unless you do
something to stop it and that's
really fundamental in how the universe
works and it's not just eggs that there
applies to although it's really useful
if you're the sort of person and
apparently these people do exist who
boil eggs and then put them back in the
fridge
who does that don't admit to it it's
okay we won't judge you and so but it's
also got much broader applicability so
this is the Hubble Space Telescope the
Hubble Ultra Deep Field which is a very
tiny part of the sky and Hubble has been
floating in free space for 25 years not
touching anything and yet it can point
to a tiny region of sky for an 11 there
are 1/2 days it did it in sections
accurately enough to take amazing images
like this so the question is how does
something that is not touching anything
how does it know where it is and the
answer is that in the middle of it it
has something that to my great
disappointment isn't a raw egg but
basically does the same job it's got
gyroscopes which are spinning and
because of the law of conservation of
angular momentum they keep spinning with
the same axis indefinitely and Hubble
kind of rotates around them and so it
can orient itself so the same little
physical law that we can play with in
the kitchen and use also explains some
of what makes possible some of the most
advanced technology of our time
and so you sort so this is the fun bit
of physics for me it's that you learn
these patterns and then you can apply
them again and again again and it's
really rewarding when you spot them in
new places this is the fun of physics I
have shown that egg video to a an
audience full of business people once
and they're all very sort of dressed up
very smartly and trying to employ
they're trying to impress their bosses
and I ran it was running out of time so
I showed the egg video and then say that
well you can work it out you can ask me
afterwards to check and then I left the
stage and then I had literally
middle-aged grown men tugging on my
sleeve afterwards saying is it this is
it this and then I said yes to it yes
right the joy that you get from like
these spotting these patterns doesn't go
away when you're an adult and that's
really important because physics is all
about patterns and the small number of
patterns give you access to all almost
all of the physics in our everyday world
and the thing that's best about this is
it evolves playing with toys things like
the eggs shouldn't be dismissed as the
mundane little things that we just give
the kids to play with on a Saturday
afternoon to keep the
quiet this is the stuff that actually
really matters because this is the laws
of the universe and it applies to eggs
and toast of all you butter side down
and all sorts of other things just as
much as it applies to modern technology
and anything else that's going on in the
world so I think we should play with
these patterns so there are basically
there are a small number of concepts
that you can become familiar with using
things in your kitchen that are really
useful for life in the outside world
you want to learn about thermodynamics a
duck is a good place to start for
example why is that feet don't get cold
and once you've got a bit of
thermodynamics with the duck you can
also explain fridges and magnets that
you can play with in your kitchen get
you two wind turbines and modern energy
generation raisins in them made which is
always a good things play with if you're
at a boring party fish some raisins out
of the bar snacks put them in some
lemonade it's got three consequences
first thing is it's quite good to watch
try it
secondly it sends the boring people away
thirdly it brings the interesting people
to you you win on all fronts and and
then there's those things you know spin
and gas laws and viscosity but these
little patterns and they'll write around
us everywhere and it's fundamentally
democratic right everybody has access to
the same physics you don't need a big
posh lab when I am when I wrote the book
and I have it the chapter on spin and
I'd written a bit about toast falling
butter side down and I gave the chapter
to a friend of mine who's not scientist
and for him to read tell me what he
thought and he took the chapter away and
he was working overseas and I got this
text message back from him a couple of
weeks later and it said um I'm an I'm at
breakfast in a posh hotel in Switzerland
and I really want to push toast off the
table because I don't believe what you
wrote and that was the good bit he
doesn't have to he can push the toast
off the table and try it for himself and
so these laws teachers too important
there's two important things to know
about science right there's the
fundamental laws that we have explained
through experience and experimentation
work right the day we drop an apple and
it goes up then we'll have a debate
about gravity up to that point we
basically know how gravity works and we
can learn the framework and then it's a
process of experimentation having
confidence in things trying things out
ccall thinking how we move science
forward and you can learn both of those
things by playing with toys in the
everyday world and it's it's really
important because you know there's all
this talk about technology we've heard
talks about quantum computing and all
these sort of mysterious far-off things
but fundamentally we still live in
bodies there are about this size we
still walk about some chairs that are
about this size we still live in the
physical world and knowing being
familiar with these concepts means we're
not helpless and I think it's really
important that we're not helpless that
society feels it can look at things
because this isn't about knowing all the
answers it's about having the framework
so you can ask the right questions and
by playing with these fundamental little
things in everyday life we gain the
confidence to ask the right questions so
there's a bigger thing in answer to
Nana's question about what you can do
when you know that because there's lots
of stuff in the everyday world that you
can do when you know that especially if
you've got eggs in the fridge and
there's a much deeper answer ah and
there's all the fun than the curiosity
that you could have playing with toys
because we shouldn't by the way toys why
should kids have all the fun right all
of us can have fun playing with toys and
we shouldn't be embarrassed about it you
can blame me it's fine so when it comes
to reasons for studying physics for
example here is the best reason I can
think of I think that each of us has
three life support systems we've got our
own body we've got a planet and we've
got our civilization each of those is an
independent life support system keeping
us alive in its own way and they all run
on this fundamental physical laws that
you can learn in the kitchen with eggs
and teacups and lemonade and everything
else you can play with so but this is
the reason for example that something
like climate change is such a serious
problem it's because it's two of these
life support systems our planet and our
civilization
kind of butting up against each other
they're in conflict and we need to
negotiate that boundary and the
fundamental physical laws that we can
learn that are the way the world around
us works are the tools at the basis of
everything they're the foundation
there's lots of things to know about in
life but knowing the foundations is
going to get you along long
way and I think this if you're not
interested in having fun with physics or
anything like that
strange but anyway apparently these
people exist and you can you surely are
interested in keeping yourself alive
right in how our life-support systems
work because the framework for physics
is remarkably constant right it's the
same in lots and lots of things that we
measure it's not going to change anytime
soon they might discover some new
quantum mechanics but apples right here
are still gonna fall down so the
question is how I got asked you know I
get asked sometimes how did you start
what's the place to start if you're
interested in the physical world and not
being helpless and in finding some toys
to play with so here is my suggestion to
you so some things to start with so it
starts right the place this starts is
that moment and adults do this right you
you're drifting along somewhere and you
spot something and your brain goes oh
that's weird
and then your conscious nose goes oh
you're an adult keep going and I think
that's the point right hold that thought
that bit where you're growing oh that's
a bit odd because there's something
there to play with and it's worth you
playing with it so that's the place to
start but if you don't have any of those
little moments on your way home from
from this event here are some things to
start with like I said put raisins in
lemonade it's highly entertaining watch
your coffee spill dry I know that sounds
a little bit like watching paint dry but
it does do quite weird things it's worth
watching get I am you know what I'm an
acquired taste at dinner parties if
there are tea cups around there are so
many things you can do to play with
teacups it's brilliant the most obvious
one is to get a teacup get a spoon tap
the teacup around the rim and listen and
you will hear something strange and the
other thing is push your toast off the
table push some toast off a table
because you can right and you'll learn
stuff from it and if you're feeling
really ambitious try and push it off in
such a way that it doesn't fall butter
side down which is possible so the point
of all of this is that first of all we
should all play with toys right we
shouldn't be afraid to investigate the
physical world for ourselves with the
tools around us because we all have
access to them it matters because if we
want to understand society if we want to
be good citizens we need to understand
the framework on which everything else
must be based so playing with
is great understanding how to keep our
life-support systems going is great but
fundamentally the thing that we need to
change in the way that we talk about
physics is that we need to understand
that physics isn't out there with weird
people and strange hieroglyphics for
somebody else in a posh lab physics is
right here it's for us and we can all
play with it thank you very much
[Applause]